let's talk about ai a little bit
what are your thoughts
about gpt3 and
language models trained with
self-supervised learning
it came out quite a bit ago but i wanted
to get your thoughts on it yeah
in the 90s i was in new zealand and
i had an amazing professor ian witton
who realized i was bored in class and
put me in his lab and he gave me the
task to discover grammatical structure
in an unknown language
and the unknown language that i picked
was english because it was the easiest
one to find corpus four construct one
and he gave me the largest computer at
the whole university it had 2 gigabytes
of ram which was amazing and i wrote
everything in c with some in-memory
compression to do statistics over the
language
and
i first would
create a dictionary of all the words
which basically tokenizes everything and
compresses things so i don't need to
store the whole world but just
a code for every word and then i was
taking this all apart in sentences and i
was trying to
find all the relationships between all
the words in the sentences and do
statistics over them
and that proved to be impossible because
the complexity is just too large so if
you want to discover the relationship
between an article and a noun and there
are three adjectives in between you
cannot do engram statistics and look at
all the possibilities that can exist at
least not with the resources that we had
back then
so i realized i need to make some
statistics over what i need to make
statistics over so i wrote something
that was pretty much a hack
that did this for um at least first
order relationships and i came up with
some kind of mutual information graph
that was indeed discovering uh something
that looks exactly like the grammatical
structure of the sentence just by trying
to encode the sentence in such a way
that the words would be written in the
optimal order
inside of the model
and
what i also found is that if we would be
able to increase the resolution of that
and
not just use this model to reproduce
grammatically correct sentences we would
also be able to correct stylistically
correct sentences by just having more
bits in these relationships and if we
wanted to have meaning we would have to
go much higher order
and i didn't know how to make higher
order models back then without spending
way more years in research on how to
make the statistics over what we need to
make statistics over
and um this thing that we cannot look at
the relationships between all the bits
in your input is being solved in
different domains in different ways so
in computer graphics the
computer vision standard method for many
years now is convolutional neural
networks convolutional neural networks
are hierarchies of filters
that exploit the fact that neighboring
pixels in images are usually
semantically related and distance pixels
and images are usually not semantically
related
so you can just by grouping the pixels
that are next to each other
hierarchically together reconstruct the
shape of objects
and this is an important prior that we
built into these models so they can
converge quickly
but this doesn't work in language for
the reason that adjacent words are often
but not always related and distant words
are sometimes related while the words in
between are not
right so how can you learn the topology
of language
and i think for for this reason that
this difficulty existed the transformer
was invented in
natural language processing not in
vision
and what the transformer is doing it's a
hierarchy of layers where every layer
learns what to pay attention to in the
given context in the previous layer
so what to make the statistics over
and the context is
significantly larger than the adjacent
word yes so the context that is that
gpt3 has been using the transformer
itself is from 2017 and it's uh wasn't
using that large of a context
openai has basically scaled up this idea
as far as they could at the time and the
context is
about 2048
symbols tokens in the language these
symbols are not characters but they take
the words and project them into a vector
space where
words that are statistically
co-occurring a lot are neighbors already
so it's already a simplification of the
problem a little bit
and so every word is basically a set of
coordinates in a high dimensional space
and then they use some kind of trick to
also encode the order of the words in a
sentence or in the not just sentence but
2048 tokens is about couple pages of
text or two and a half pages of text
and so they managed to do pretty
exhaustive statistics over the potential
relationships
between two pages of text which is
tremendous right i was just using a
single sentence back then
and uh i was um only looking for first
order relationships and they were really
looking for much much higher level
relationships and what they discover
after they fed this with an enormous
amount of tremendous pretty much the
written internet or a subset of it that
had some quality but
substantial portion of the common draw
that they're not only able to reproduce
style but they're also able to reproduce
some pretty detailed semantics like
being able to um add three-digit numbers
and multiply two-digit numbers or to
translate between programming languages
and things like that
so the results that gbt3 got i think
we're amazing by the way um
i actually didn't check carefully it's
funny you just mention
how you couple semantics to the
multiplication is it able to do some
basic math on two uh two digit numbers
yes
okay interesting i thought
i thought there's a lot of
failure cases yeah but basically it
fails if you take larger digit numbers
so four-digit numbers and so on uh makes
carrying mistakes and so on and if you
take large larger numbers you don't get
useful results at all
and
this could be
an issue of the training set where there
are not many examples of successful
long-form edition and standard uh human
written text and humans aren't very good
at doing three-digit numbers either yeah
they're not you're not writing a lot
about it
and
the other thing is that the loss
function that is being used is only
minimizing surprises so it's predicting
what comes next in the typical text it's
not trying to go for causal closure
first as we do yeah
and but the fact that that kind of
uh prediction works
to generate text that's semantically
rich and consistent
is interesting yeah so yeah so it's
amazing that it's able to uh
generate symmetric consistent text it's
not consistent so the problem is that it
loses coherence at some point but it's
also i think not correct to say that
gptc is unable to deal with semantics at
all because you ask it to perform
certain transformations in text and it
performs this transformation and text
and the kind of additions that it's able
to perform are transformations in text
right and
there are proper semantics involved you
can also do more there was a paper that
was generating
lots and lots of
mathematically correct
text
and was feeding this into a transformer
and as a result it was able to learn how
to do differentiation integration in
race that according to the authors
mathematica could not
to which some of the people in
mathematica responded that uh they were
not using the mathematica in the right
way and so on i have not really followed
the the resolution of this conflict this
this part as a small tangent i really
don't like in machine learning papers
which
they often
do um
anecdotal evidence they'll find like one
example in some kind of specific use of
mathematica and demonstrate look here's
they'll show successes and failures but
they won't have a very clear
representation
of how many cases this actually
represents yes but i think as the first
paper this is a pretty good start and
yeah so uh the whole message i think is
that
the authors could get better results
from this and their
experiments then they could get from the
vein which they were using computer
algebra systems which means uh that was
not nothing yeah and uh it's able to
perform substantially better than gptsv
can based on a much larger amount of
training data using the same underlying
algorithm
you